you know we love the loud house on this
channel and we think it's absolutely
hilarious but sometimes the episodes are
actually funnier to adults than they are
to kids from totally inappropriate to
references to inside jokes only adults
will understand
wait until you see which moments made it
on our list now let's check out the loud
house moments kids won't understand city
slickers let's start with some of the
moments from season 3 in the episode
called city slickers we get to learn a
few more details about rognons and de
Lincoln's relationship and to be honest
it's quite complicated Ronnie doesn't
exactly treat Lincoln in the best way
possible but as Lincoln looks back at
their weird relationship he flashbacks
to the time in Ronny an put a pie in his
pants now we might be totally reaching
here but we have a feeling that this is
also a brief shout-out to the iconic pie
pan scene from The Simpsons
he said pie pants hi pants let's be
honest cartoon characters don't really
get a pie down their pants often it's
such a waste so could this be a very
subtle reference actually meant for
adults we have a feeling not many kids
would appreciate that moment well unless
you're Lincoln who totally enjoys it
I've missed her seriously adults will
probably understand these type of
relationship dynamics a lot more than
kids and to be completely honest it's
definitely not a completely healthy
dynamic either fool me twice fool me
twice is a fun episode that's all about
trying to avoid the ranch April Fool's
Day pranks and in order to do that the
family decides to hire stunt doubles Oh
[Music]
pair good till the episode also pokes
fun at the fact that Lincoln is the only
member of the family with white hair
let's be honest it's difficult to find
the stunt double with Lincoln's exact
same look but the best part comes when
the stunt double basically says this
you're 11 and you have white hair I did
the best I could he also says that he
came out from retirements from this gig
and Lincoln clearly wasn't convinced
until he pointed out that he just sits
around reading in his underwear
it was only then that Lincoln realizes
he's perfect
could this be a very subtle joke
referring to what Lincoln's actually
doing in his room or better yet what his
stunt double is actually doing we've
seen Lincoln reading in this underwear a
lot but imagine doing that as an old man
kind of weird right his done dub will
also never specified what kind of things
he's actually read nothing to see here
kids only adults will get this one the
loudest yard the loudest yard is one of
those episodes that's totally adorable
but it comes with a scene that
definitely shocks more parents than it
does kids we all know Lincoln isn't
exactly an active kid and he spends way
too much time indoors it's not healthy
to sit around playing video games all
day actually mom out read aloud is
actually right it's really not healthy
to spend so much time inside so she
tries to get Lincoln to be more active
it's safe to say that it's not actually
working but one of the weirdest moments
ever comes from the living room scene we
first see the television and read aloud
making a weird counting noises
see exercise can be fun
she says that exercise can be fun and
then this happens we I really allowed
and clear mom
okay adults you have to admit that cliff
made you feel just a little bit weird
inside especially since Lincoln makes a
funny smirk as he looks at his mother's
behind of course it's because he found a
way to still not actually exercise but
honestly that's just one of those
moments that really wasn't meant for
kids
Luann's funds Luann's puns might be
annoying to the loud family but we
absolutely love them she has dropped
some serious gems over the years but
here are some of our faves in the very
first episode the kids argue because the
lights went out in the house LuAnn says
that she knows why the lights went out
and it's because they liked each other
each other come on that's a totally
underrated joke in an episode called get
the message she says if they heard about
the thief who stole a calendar and then
she adds that he got 12 months did you
hear the one about the thief who stole a
calendar he got 12 months we bet adults
got that one better than the kids and in
undie pressure she busts out one of the
best knock-knock jokes ever when a
delivery man knocks LuAnn replies with
who's there
after she says delivery man who the guy
is clearly not entertained but LuAnn
says that he needs to work on his
delivery delivery man whoo come on kid
it's raided seriously she's absolutely
hilarious
BRB totally stealing some of these jokes
sweet and sour sweet and sour is
definitely one of those favorite loud
house episodes it's just so much fun to
see in the family do something outside
of their house will be so good you won't
even know we're there we promise of
course everything just turned into a
complete mess
but one of the most shocking moments
comes from the fact that the parents
were even more mischievious than the
kids and that's the first time that's
ever happened but we bet most kids
didn't get the subtle message in the
Marco Polo game that actually got the
parents kicked out even the parents
themselves say that the kids are far too
young to understand it honestly it's
very rare to see the parents misbehave
in general but it's even worse when
they're hiding it from their kids but by
the looks of it that Marco Polo game was
very necessary for Rita and Lin seniors
relationship back in blacks the entire
episode revolves around Lucy getting a
crush on a boy that's totally different
from her hi I'm Lucy and of course the
loud sisters all recommends Lucy to
change her look to make herself be more
like them the girls all test different
styles on Lucy that will help get
Rocky's attention what are you doing
eventually she has her hair dyed blonde
and becomes a complete girly girl
she also puts on an accent and basically
acts like a completely different girl oh
great shot
rocky bear even though the message is
clear we have a feeling most kids don't
understand it as girls develop their
first crushes they'll try to do whatever
they can to make sure the other person
likes them but the truth is you
shouldn't change yourself for someone
else at all it's a subject adults
definitely know more about kids will
appreciate this moment a lot more once
they're older and see just how much Lucy
actually wanted to change patching
things up patchy things up episode from
season two comes with some unexpected
subtle messages that will probably go
over kids heads we all know Clyde is
just a little bit special this episode
clearly wanted to keep the humor of
Clyde's character but we also feel like
it's it's a different more important
message this one might go over kids
heads but we bet parents caught on the
subtle scene after all the boys are
pretty much hiding in a closet and once
they come out they're both wearing
dresses
there's no cookies in here either I'm
starting to lose it Lincoln but then
they go back in to avoid being seen and
the second time they come out
Lincoln's back to his normal clothes but
Clyde still wearing the dress and he
even adds a tiara to go with it Clyde oh
right what was I thinking
the loud house is extremely progressive
when it comes to LGBTQ characters so we
wouldn't be surprised if the moment is
also a subtle hint either way you go
Clyde you look awesome Cheaper by the
Dozen the whole Bobby and Laurie
relationship definitely has moments that
only adults will understand unless
you've been in love you won't know what
it's like
but there's one moment in season two
that took everyone by surprise
it's called Cheaper by the Dozen and
everything revolves around Lincoln and
Clyde suspecting Bobby has a side chick
[Music]
the entire theme of this episode is
definitely more suited for adults but
the most shocking moment comes when they
overhear an older woman say to Bobbie to
slip out of those clothes to get started
why don't just slip down those clothes
and we'll get started
Clive then covers his eyes saying he's
not allowed to watch r-rated movies
which basically means this scene is
definitely not for kids
we can also see Bobby actually dropping
his pants sure it all turned out to be
completely innocent but that's far too
many and you endows for a kid's show
like Clyde said we prefer below r-rated
moments thank you very much lock and
loud okay we all know Lisa has some
quirks about her that are probably seen
as slightly weird and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that well that is
until you start giving out bad vibes in
lock & Mild we get to see those bad
vibes firsthand Lisa is normally
ridiculously cute but this was just a
little bit too much throughout the
episode she wants to get her siblings to
help her with her bathroom studies she
installs cameras in the actual toilet
and she actually wants stool samples I
also need a stool sample for your
security system
she claims there for her security system
but her dubious smile tells the
different story
sure that kid seriously that went just a
little bit overboard not to mention that
the whole thing with cameras in the
bathroom is just a whole nother level of
weird
don't stole samples but we have a
feeling many adults will understand
Elise's weird quest better than the kids
sure it might be gross but some people
just like gross things right and we
think this is what the show was hinting
at anyways
that's just too much information let's
move on a tale of two tables season one
has plenty of hilarious moments but one
of them stands out the most and we bet
you missed it it happens in the fourth
episode titled a tale of two tables it's
all about Lincoln proving he's mature
enough to sit at the adult table
honestly that alone will make sense to a
lot of adults who to this day sit at the
kids table because they're still seen as
kids in most families the kiddie table
is something you only see in holidays
but in this episode Lucy and Lincoln
have a funny exchange about broccoli
Lucy asked Lincoln how he can eat
broccoli when it's suffered so much to
get there how can you eat broccoli when
you know how much it's suffered to get
here
of course Lincoln replies that broccoli
doesn't feel pain and then Lucy pretty
much makes him listen to the broccoli
screaming on the inside broccoli doesn't
feel pain oh no listen to the broccoli
screaming Lincoln if you're vegan or
vegetarian you've probably heard the
argument that plants feel pain just as
much as animals whether intentional or
not this moment looks like it was a
reference to that we've been adults have
had debates that are definitely similar
potty-mouth okay not going to lie the
potty mouth episode from season two was
absolutely hilarious and one of our
favorites no one likes to see their kids
swear
even though adults tend to swear most of
the time but being a potty mouth can get
you in a lot of trouble as a child in
potty mouth really is apparently
overheard saying the D word
[Music]
but adults probably know that unless she
seen something highly inappropriate
there is no D word that would really be
bad which is probably what makes this
episode so hilarious to watch we
absolutely love how the kids realize
they're all saying bad words that might
influence Lily in the end it turns out
that the D word was something entirely
different and totally innocent but then
it gets worse because she actually drops
an actual curse word that gets bleeped
out it's definitely one of those
episodes that parents understand more
than kids and we bet you laughed out
loud at the ending the loudest mission
breaking the fourth wall is loud houses
specialty and it makes complete sense
considering Lincoln is telling us about
his life but did you notice that this is
exactly what Lincoln told Ronnie and she
should do here's something that might
help you out it always helps me it's one
of those moments where it's clear that
letting it out and talking to someone
definitely helps but of course the loud
house made this work in a cartoon type
of way so Ronnie Ann isn't just talking
to anyone she's talking to us the
audience huh Lincoln was right it does
help talking to you guys this also means
that talking it out is one of those
things Lincoln does to decrease the
stress of living with a large family and
this is also an important life lesson
for anyone who's having way too many
things on their plates of course talking
to a camera might not always be a
solution but talking about your problems
is definitely a way forward not to
mention that this entire exchange makes
us excited for the Louis Casas Grandes
spin-off show Driving Miss hazy another
underrated episode comes from the very
first season Lincoln basically helps
Lennie try to pass her driver's test and
he does it because he's tired of doing
favors for Lori this is the love laundry
I don't think it's worth it do you want
a ride to the comic book store or not if
you're an older child you definitely
remember doing this exact same to your
siblings the entire episode definitely
brings back memories for all adults who
were in the
Zak's same situation passing a driver's
test definitely isn't easy and many fell
multiple times and put in a lot of hours
Laurie also sabotages Lenny to make sure
she doesn't actually pass and she does
it in the most hilarious way possible
check your mirrors
seriously the entire episode is
absolutely hilarious and it's definitely
a reminder of what it was like living
without a driver's license of course
it's also a reminder of what it was like
getting that driver's license it's just
one of those things kids won't
understand and tell they're older and
they have to go through it themselves in
the sweet spot the sweet spot is a
fairly ordinary episode the one thing
that stood out was a hilarious moment
with Lenny's nightmare if you missed it
you definitely have to re-watch the
scene because honestly it's totally
relatable actually the entire episode of
having the perfect spot in the car is
relatable I'm sorry you had to see that
having the wrong sister next to me could
totally wreck the sweet spot if you have
a large family you can totally relate
sitting next to the wrong person can
ruin your entire ride but that's not
what we're here for
Lenny actually has one of the most
hilarious fashion nightmares if you're a
modern fashionista that just can't get
on board the old-school clothes
you're definitely feeling this on a
spiritual level scrunchies leg warmers
socks and sandals we bet this gave
adults who remember those days a good
giggle we just love that her fashionable
character is so in love with current
fashions she even dreams about it
don't worry Lenny we promise has socks
for the sandals and are definitely never
making a comeback
hopefully space invader and our final
moment belongs to the episode that's
still the most shocking every time we
watch it it's by far one of the most
subtle moments on the show that can
easily fly past the kids heads but
adults are definitely aware of
Nickelodeon's innuendos so this didn't
go unnoticed the moment happens in
season 1 episode 6 be called space
invader Lynn and Lucy have a fight so
Lincoln lets Lynn cool off in his room
immediately notices that Lincoln's room
has in her words a lack of balls no
soccer balls no footballs no baseball's
no balls good thing I brought my own
innocent right well it would be if it
wasn't for the pause right before Lin
said it's a good thing she brought her
balls even British TV thinks that it's a
bit inappropriate because that pause was
actually cut out from the UK version of
the episode you know I'm noticing a
complete lack of balls in this room no
soccer balls no footballs no baseballs
no balls and we've got adults understand
this slightly more than kids but
interestingly even Nickelodeon thinks
some of their own moments shouldn't be
meant for kids
honestly we bet there are a ton of more
moments where a loud house joke went
over all of our heads if you remember
any make sure to post it in the comment
section and that's it for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more feel-good contents thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]